hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es einen wunsch rezept ich
habe eine super girl torte gebacken und
zwar war der wunsch von einem ganz
besonderen supergirl und zwar von uns
zum kleinen seesterne leider werde es
vielleicht ein bisschen mitbekommen hat
wir hatten ja vor ein paar monaten ein
video darüber gemacht über die leider
die leider vor vier jahren an krebs
erkrankt ist erkrankt ist und wir hatten
den spendenaufruf gemacht und ihr habt
alle ganz fleißig mitgeholfen damit ihr
leider die therapie in den usa machen
kann
aktuell ist sie gerade nicht mehr den
usa sondern in istanbul
und zwar ziemlich traurig die therapie
hat bei ihr leider nicht angeschlagen
und deswegen hat sie sich gewünscht dass
sie einfach noch mal nach istanbul
reisen kann weil sie dort einfach die
schönsten erinnerungen mit ihrer familie
hatte und dass sie dort einfach die
restliche zeit die ihr bleibt verbringen
kann
ich hab mir leider auf dem flug von
metal über frankfurt nach istanbul am
frankfurter flughafen besucht
da musste ich natürlich eine
sondergenehmigung einholen damit ich
überhaupt an den flughafen kommen konnte
in diesem transitbereich wo sie war
und habt ihr da getroffen und habe mich
dann so 33 stunden mit ihr unterhalten
und habe einfach die zeit mit ihr
verbracht und ich muss dazu sagen ihr
leid wirklich ein sehr sehr tapferes
mädchen und sehr starkes mädchen und für
100 mich wirklich immer wieder von neuem
und hat wirklich ganz viele menschen
mitgerissen und ich denke ja das ist
einmal verdient hat dass ich jetzt diese
torte mache sie hat sich von mir diese
supergirl torte gewünscht wer sie
verfolgt auf facebook zum beispiel der
weiß dass sie diese super girl katie hat
lila und rosa ist die farbe und deswegen
sollte es eben auch eine super girl
torte sein was natürlich auch perfekt zu
ihr und der wunsch war dass im inneren
eine schokoladentorte ist eine
ein schoko teig und eine
schokoladencreme ganz ohne früchte hat
sie sich gewünscht sowie samira geben
auch gerne isst und dekoriert habe ich
sie mit fondant habe eine rosa schicht
treffer hier das supergirl logo und hier
halten habe ich noch so eine wand
gemacht und zwar steht da in graffiti
schrift darauf supergirl leiter und
einfach noch so ein paar feinheiten wie
zum beispiel sisters teil weil ihre
schwester alena sie natürlich auch die
ganze zeit über begleitet hat und die
beiden eine richtig tolle bindung auch
haben und ja familie ganz in so einem
herzchen mit drin weil einfach ihre
eltern und ihre schwester immer für sie
da sind und ich hoffe natürlich dass er
die torte gefällt und ja das auch euch
gefällt und es ist wirklich so mischen
video noch nie vor schwer gefallen wie
dieses und ich muss auch sagen ich habe
versucht auszublenden während dem backen
dass die torte für die leider ist weil
ich einfach nicht traurig sein wollte
auch im video
aber ich hoffe dass es ihr einfach
nochmal kraft gibt für ihre zeit und ich
würde einfach mal gleich mit der torte
starten und werde zuerst einmal den teig
zubereiten starte ich mit der torte ich
habe jetzt ein bisschen was vorbereitet
und zwar habe ich hier zwei saftige
böden gebacken und was in das
schokoladen würden nach meinem
grundrezept was ihr auf meinem blog und
auch in den videos findet und ich habe
hier eine portion schokolade hergestellt
und zwar mit vollmilchschokolade also es
ist ein reiner schokoladenkuchen
so wie sich die leider den auch
gewünscht hat jetzt habe ich hier die
böden in 20 zentimeter durchmesser
gebacken und wetzt einmal vom bug ring
lösen
sich das team vom blech herunter und ich
finde es ganz toll dass ich hier 220 er
böden auf dem großen blech backen kann
weil man dann einfach nur einmal den
backofen anschließen muss man geht eben
beides auf einmal sehe ich die böden mit
einem torten retter runter und ich sind
jetzt natürlich noch relativ frisch also
man hat jetzt auch einmal vorbereiten
können und schon einen tag vorher backen
können aber ich verweise jetzt einfach
frisch weiter
die bröseln dann zwar ein bisschen aber
das geht auf jeden fall auch die böden
schneide ich jetzt einmal waagerecht
durch dann kann ich sie nämlich auch
noch viel und es geht am besten mit
einer torte segel
jetzt nehme ich mir ein cache bord und
wartet 25 cm durchmesser und auch 1 cm
stark das heißt es ist stabil genug
damit orte darauf platzieren kann und
dafür streichelt ein bisschen von der
garage auf die platte damit die torte
darauf nicht verrutscht und da kommt
jetzt der erste boden drauf und die
torte wird jetzt mit der garage auch
gefüllt man könnte jetzt auch mit
marmelade zum beispiel für das ist
einfach je nach geschmack und trinken
brauche ich den boden jetzt wirklich
nicht er ist wirklich total saftig
natürlich kann man ihn auch trinken zum
beispiel mit kaffee mit likör oder mit
säften dann kann man auch nochmal
geschmack mit reinbringen arbeitsplätzen
rheinischen abend orte werden
unser fülle unsterblich ist die gesamte
torte
und jetzt stelle ich die torte für etwa
eine halbe stunde im kühlschrank die
gerne stelle ich jetzt auch noch mal für
etwa zehn minuten in den kühlschrank
denn die habe ich heute auch ganz frisch
zubereitet und dies noch nicht ganz fest
und zum einstreichen für die torte
sollte sie schon ein bisschen fest auf
einem nicht so ganz flüssig jetzt stelle
ich die deko wand her und dafür habe ich
jetzt weiße blüten passte und roten
fondant und mische den jetzt eins zu
eins von beidem habe ich jetzt so etwa
150 gramm
und dann entsteht daraus modelle von
land und den kann ich benutzen um die
wand herzustellen denn die soll ja gut
durchtrocknen und stabil sein und
deswegen ist da jetzt die blöden pasta
erforderlich oder ihr nehmt einfach 300
gramm roten fondant un-mission ein
bisschen cmc also zellulose kurve ein
dann wird es nämlich auch schon fest um
weil mir das jetzt so wieder zu hell
geworden ist nämlich einfach noch ein
bisschen rote lebensmittelfarbe passte
und muss sie mit ein
die modelliermasse rolle ich jetzt auf
etwas becker stärker aus man könnte
jetzt auch puderzucker nehmen aber
puderzucker macht modelle schokolade
modelliermasse und auch vorne immer
relativ klebrig deswegen arbeite ich
lieber mit becker stärke und die kann
man eben auch danach wieder schön ab
rudern
damit das ganze jetzt gleichmäßig dick
wird nämlich zwei hölzer und zwar haben
die einen abstand von drei millimetern
und es muss jetzt auch gar nicht zu hoch
werden sondern eher in die länge gehen
meine torte ist etwa acht zentimeter
hoch also mit von land und so weiter und
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier diese matte
etwa 20 zentimeter hoch um 38 zentimeter
lang schneiden damit einfach hinten nur
so eine kleine wand entsteht und hier
hinten was ich einfach ein bisschen mehr
puffer und macht so etwa 35 zentimeter
und jetzt nämlich ein geodreieck am
besten ist es wenn ihr ein größeres habt
und kann jetzt diese mauer struktur
machen die geht ganz einfach
ich werde jetzt immer so etwa einen
zentimeter hoch eine linie ziehen
das markiert jetzt so ein bisschen mit
dem anderen lineal und vater noch mal
mit einem modelle werkzeug nach
den oberen teil den habe ich jetzt nicht
ausgefüllt in der verschwindet sowieso
hinter der torte
jetzt kommen diese querstreifen und
sondern die einzelnen backsteine sein
und da ist jetzt nur ganz wichtig dass
sie die versetzt macht denn die mauer
verläuft es so dass immer zwei backstein
unten und einer oben in der mitte ist
und da ist jetzt wichtig dass wir da
einen größeren abstand nehmen damit es
eben nicht quadratisch ist und ich mache
jetzt zwei zentimetern
ich habe die mauer strukturiert und
jetzt werde ich so etwa 10 bis 15
minuten antrocknen lassen und dann geht
es gleich damit weiter die torte ist
jetzt etwas durch gekühlt und jetzt kann
ich sie mit der restlichen ghanas
bestreichen
dafür streicht erstmal eine dünne
schicht drauf stellte zehn minuten kühl
und dann streiche ich sie nochmals blatt
die torte ist jetzt fertig eingestrichen
die stelle ich jetzt meinen kühlschrank
für etwa eine halbe stunde
und ich wollte ich noch sagen ich habe
nicht alle vier teigboden benutzt
sondern nur drei den einen habe ich
jetzt hier gelassen weil ansonsten die
torte einfach zu hoch wird und die torte
nehme ich jetzt und nehme die restliche
kanal und kann sie einstreichen und die
können wir dann später einfach so
vernaschen
oder man kann zum beispiel kate post
raus machen die mauer ist so ein
bisschen an getrocknet und hier habe ich
weiße blüten passt der ganz dünn
ausgerollt unserer blüten passte
deswegen weil man sie ganz den ausfallen
kann
und weil sie schnell an trocknet und
hier werde jetzt mit einem lebensmittel
farbstift haben den schriftzug drauf
schreiben und zwar schreibe ich das
supergirl leiter und das soll jetzt ein
bisschen aussehen wie graffiti auf der
maur deswegen errichtet in
großbuchstaben zu schreiben und einfach
so ganz frei auseinander raus
den schriftzug werde ich jetzt
ausschneiden und zwar nämlich darunter
ein brett weil auch silikon matten mal
nicht schneiden darf
und jetzt werde ich es mit einem ganz
scharfen karte ausschneiden und während
ich das jetzt noch aus schneide könnt
ihr euch schon mal anschauen was nicht
vor zwei tagen für die torte vorbereitet
habe
für eine richtige super geld hatte
brauchen wir natürlich auch ein super
globe und kbc und superman logo einfach
aus dem internet heruntergeladen und
ausgedruckt und hier bereits
ausgeschnitten und zwar geht es ganz gut
mit einem cutter und da habe ich jetzt
auch diese schwarze linie entfernt denn
die werde ich später dann beim
aufbringen auf die torten dran machen
jetzt muss ich dieses logo auch aus
etwas modelliermasse ausschneiden die
habe ich jetzt auch bereits dünn
ausgerollt und einfach fünf minuten
antrocknen lassen
jetzt nehme ich einfach etwas kokosfett
und reibe damit die modelliermasse ein
damit einfach das logo schön glatt auch
liegt
einfach ein bisschen glatt streichen
dann verrutscht ist nämlich auch nicht
jetzt kann ich hier einfach der linien
entlang ausschneiden
jetzt geht es weiter mit der wand und
zwar werde ich jetzt dieses rot damit so
ein bisschen echter aussieht und aus
sowieso backsteine werde ich hier drei
prüfer farben nehmen und zwar habe ich
ja mal an schwarzen rot und dann so ein
schwarz-rot- gemischt und es geht jetzt
einfach ganz trocken mit einem schönen
weißen pinsel und und vier immer an den
stellen entlang und mache ein mal heller
und dunkler gestanden
jetzt habe ich hier noch ein bisschen
gelbe prüfer farbe und damit hey leute
ich jetzt so ein paar stellen also ein
paar helle stellen damit die mauer etwas
echt aussieht und hier außen schneide
ich mit einem cutter und paar steine weg
damit der bauer nicht so gerade ist so
ein bisschen abgebrochen aussieht
und die schrift wird jetzt mit hilfe von
essbaren kleber einfach aufgibt
jetzt mal ich noch ein paar feinheiten
mit lebensmittel farbstiften auf die
mauer drauf das ist wirklich wie sonne
sind alte stadtmauer aussieht wie
einfach jeder was drauf schreibt der
irgendwelche nähe kommt
ich habe jetzt hier 750 gramm rosalyn
fondant und rollt es jetzt schön aus und
überzieht an die torte damit
jetzt kann ich die torte zusammenstellen
und zwar werde jetzt das supergirl logo
drauf geklebt ist es jetzt schon schön
angetrocknet coppola und zwar geht es
wieder mit essbarem kleber an
jetzt kommt hier noch eine umrandung
drum herum weil ich finde dass hebt dann
dieses logo einfach mal vor es mache ich
jetzt hier mit meiner von der modelle
presse und hier vorne habe ich eine
dünne scheibe drin eine lok scheibe und
da kommt jetzt schwarze von 3 in dem ich
bereits gut weiß geknetet habe
und durch die kurbel bewegung kommt
jetzt hier vorne ein dünner langer
gleichmäßiger strang raus und den klebe
ich dann um das logo herum
jetzt verlässt die taten fertig hier
unten das skateboard über denke ich
jetzt auch noch und zwar mit schwarzem
fondant da kommt jetzt einfach ein
bisschen kleber drauf es war kleber
natürlich und dem verteile ich jetzt mit
einem pinsel ganz grob
und hier habe ich jetzt schon ein stück
von damit bereits den aufgerollt und das
lege ich es drum herum und schneidet
dann die reste reck
jetzt habe ich hier noch eine letzte
dekoration für die torte und zwar habe
ich hier die skyline von istanbul
ausgeschnitten
dafür habe ich schwarze modell
schokolade dünn ausgerollt und auf
dieses schneidebrett gelegt und habe die
skyline von istanbul einfach aus dem
internet ausgedruckt und ausgeschnitten
und gestern mit einem ganz dünnen kader
aus geschnitten und jetzt muss ich das
natürlich ganz vorsichtig auf die torte
bekommen ohne es zu spiegeln übrigens
die skyline von istanbul genommen weil
die leider gerade istanbul ist und sich
gewünscht hat eben ihre restliche zeit
noch dort zu verbringen
und ja deswegen passt es wirklich sehr
gut
jetzt habe ich hier ein stück backpapier
und zwar gibt es die andere auf einer
papierrolle und das habe ich ein
gefährdet mit etwas kokosfett damit
jetzt diese skyline einfach schön darauf
kleben bleibt klebe ich das hier an
jetzt streit ich hier ganz vorsichtig
darüber ohne jetzt die skyline zu
beschädigen
das ganze umgedreht und ich habe hier
seine flexible matten und bin jetzt kann
ich die matte vorsichtig abziehen
ein bisschen was verrutscht ist könnt
ihr das nochmal mit dem cuttermesser ein
bisschen zurechtrücken
jetzt kann ich die torte zusammensetzen
und zwar hab ich diese mauer einfach
derzeit so ein bisschen antrocknen
lassen in meinem verstellbaren
tortenring und zwar auf einem stück
backpapier so dass einfach schon mal die
form eingenommen wird
ohne das ganze eben dann zu beschädigen
jetzt streiche ich etwas kleber auf den
unteren teil
das ist vorsichtig heraus
und kann sitzt um die torte herumlägen
jetzt nehme ich die skyline und streifte
auch ein bisschen kleber drauf aber
nicht so viel damit es einfach nicht am
rand wieder raus läuft
da kann ich sehr vorsichtig ankleben
die torte ist fertig und sie wird jetzt
noch ergänzt mit dem seestern den hat
mir letzte woche bei einer signierstunde
im globus in st wendel eine zuschauerin
geschenkt was heißt geschenkt werde mir
gegeben damit ich ihn leider übergebe
vielleicht noch ganz kurz zur leider ist
gerade in istanbul und ich hab sie vor
eineinhalb wochen ungefähr besucht da
lag sie im koma das war auch ziemlich
schnell also saison nach istanbul
geflogen und dann ging's er ganz rapide
ganz schlecht und dann ist sie eben ins
koma gefallen und ich habe sie dann eben
besucht um auch der familie einfach ein
bisschen unterstützung zu sein und um
für ihre schwester da zu sein für die
alena und war da zwei tage dort und habe
mich dann ein bisschen um alena
gekümmert habe einfach so eine schöne
zeit mit ihr verbracht während die
eltern eben eigentlich fast 24 stunden
bei leiter im krankenhaus waren und als
ich wieder zurück gereist bin war das
für mich also es war ein ziemlich
gemischte gefühle auch traurig dass ich
sehe dass ich nicht mehr mit ihr
sprechen konnte
aber an meinem abreisetag war es so dass
sie aus dem koma wieder erwacht ist und
wir haben uns wirklich alle sehr gefreut
natürlich weiß man nicht ist es das
letzte aufbäumen oder wird sie
tatsächlich wieder gesund man natürlich
wieder hoffnung geschöpft und ich bin
wirklich mit total gemischten gefühlen
nach haus geflogen habe auch im flieger
ich hab dann musik gehört und habe
geweint und gelacht und weil ich jetzt
nicht wusste was passiert jetzt was
passiert wenn ich's handy wieder an
mache was kommt für die nachricht und
ich habe dazu einen langen text bei
facebook geschrieben den ich euch unten
in der infobox einfach verlinken werde
dass sie einfach so ein bisschen den
hintergrund wer jetzt genau warum sehen
lässt man einfach diesen text geht die
infobox ist diese text verlinkt geht man
da reinen lesen text und da ist
eigentlich das was ich sagen will es die
ganze zeit und diese torte wirst du ja
eigentlich jetzt am freitag hast ja vor
wieder zu genau also im moment ist es so
dass sie jetzt aus dem krankenhaus
wieder draußen ist
aber sie ist wie gesagt austherapiert
und wird jetzt einfach die letzte zeit
mit ihrer familie in einer wohnung
verbringen da ist eine palliativ
mediziner dabei und wird sie begleiten
und ja ich habe jetzt vor
am freitag also jetzt am freitag noch
mal nach istanbul zu pflegen damit ich
sie einfach noch mal sehen und ich werde
die torte dann noch mal packen damit wir
eben noch mal frisch ist und welche dann
leider übergeben vielleicht möchte sie
dann ein stück probieren ohne ihre
allgemein allen bedanken für die ganze
unterstützung den ganzen stütze für die
ganzen leben worte der papa hat er
leider also nicht alles aber natürlich
ganz viele kommentare während ihrer
krankheit zeit vorgelesen und seid ihr
wirklich auch super viel kraft gegeben
immer und seid echt immer viel gekämpft
und war immer stark und jetzt ist
einfach an einem punkt wo sie sagt sie
möchte jetzt nicht mehr stark seien sie
mich nicht mehr kämpfen sie möchte
einfach in frieden gehen und ich denke
das sollte er so ermöglichen und wie
gesagt also wichtig ist dass wir jetzt
auch so wird darüber reden und so viel
über philosophieren wie alles geht aber
wie gesagt lässt diesen text bei auf der
seite von der cd bei facebook diesen
link folgt diesem link an und liest man
diesen ganzen text und da ist vieles
gesagt nur bei euch allen herz ist
einfach nur bedanken für das nächste
halbe jahr wurde uns damit begleitet hat
ja und ich hoffe liebe leider das tier
diese torte gefällt und ich setze dir
vorbei bringen auf jeden fall und den
kleinen ruhestellung also vielen dank
fürs einschalten und wir haben jetzt
beschlossen die torte nicht
anzuschneiden irgendwie bringe ich es
gerade nicht übersetzt also bislang als
wie lang